sometimes in life to be successful
oftentimes most of the time you have to
follow your instincts you have to follow
your gut you have to your parents may
say wrong you're whoever may say wrong
but you have to do it you have to love
what you do it solves a lot of problems
because when you love what you do
would you really love what you do you
work harder I tell the story a Wall
Street Titan big guy he has a son so he
wants his son Alex to go into the firm
of course in the meantime all these kids
are graduating from Wharton and Harvard
and Stanford and they're just eating
Alex's lunch he doesn't have a chance
and he doesn't like it he's not liking
what he's doing you got to love what you
do so one day I actually come why don't
you leave your father's brutal the
father's just killing the guys tell him
you don't have what it takes you got to
leave him he said I just can't Donald
Sony he's a member of a very good golf
club in Westchester and they put him in
charge of redoing the course they're
doing this big renovation of the course
it's a very good cut Club and he's there
every morning at 5:00 in the morning he
doesn't leave he did such an
unbelievable job
the contractors respected him everybody
respected him and they give him an honor
and this is a tough group of people that
have this learn that Club came in under
budget faster by two months he did an
unbelievable job and the quality of the
work was ten times what they ever
anticipated so they gave him a medal I
said you know Alex you were to go and do
this for a living you want to be a
builder whether it's houses or clubs or
golf courses renovation or this oh my
father would go crazy at never let me so
Alex went back to Wall Street where he
was miserable and a year later he quit
and he started doing renovations of
houses and clubs and different things
and he's doing great so you've got to
love what you do you just watched two
amazing clips from Donald Trump
take the next three minutes to sit
quietly and think about how to apply
them to your business and your life
believe
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]